All right, now that we have our material in a position
where we can start testing,
what we're gonna do now is we're gonna create
just a basic level.
And inside the basic level,
we're gonna make a very, very simple landscape
that we can apply a material instance
of our material to, to start testing.
And one of the things that we're gonna be testing for
is this.
We wanna make sure that when we get to this point,
everything is working because it's a lot easier
to fix errors now than wait to the very end
and then try to go through and fix everything.
So let's pop over to the editor.
We're just gonna come up to file, new level,
and we're gonna select the basic new level,
and we're gonna hit create.
All right, and then I'm just gonna do,
select this little plane right here and just hit delete
and then come up here.
Actually first hit control space
and we need to make an instance of our material.
So we're gonna right click on this,
create material instance.
I am gonna remove this MAT from the front of this,
just a personal preference, make sure that's selected.
And now I'm gonna come up here to my landscape
and with our material, I'm gonna go ahead
and press this use selected asset from content browser.
That's gonna give us this instance.
And then I'm gonna set this to,
leave it at 15 by 15 and hit create.
So this is gonna create my landscape.
And then the next thing I need to do here
is just add a few little height variations
so that we can actually see some of this stuff working.
So there is a little bit of height variation.
And if we notice,
I'm not actually getting anything in here,
I just have basically grass.
So let's go ahead and kick out of our landscape tool.
And then what we're gonna do
is we're gonna select our landscape.
And then in our details panel,
we're gonna look for our landscape material
and just double click on it to open it up.
I'm gonna bring this over here on screen
so we can see this.
And first things first,
let's go ahead and head to our slope contrast
and our slope fall off power.
Now I'm gonna slip my slope contrast to two
and then my slope fall off power to three.
And let's go ahead and see if we're getting
any types of details in here with this.
So we're getting a little bit,
there's a couple of things are happening here.
We're actually seeing the blending being done.
So what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna come up to this distance blend
and I'm gonna set this to a value of like five.
So we have that at a value of like 5,000.
The other thing that I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna pop back into my landscape mode,
bring my brush down a little bit,
maybe use a clay brush here
and try and get some more,
there we go, get a little bit more vertical face going.
Once I do that, we're gonna be able to see
the difference between the two a lot easier.
So there we go, got a little bit more vertical going.
So we can see here the adjustment between the two.
If I come in here to our slope contrast
and I kind of adjust this a little bit,
let's set it to like three, there we go.
And then let's see if we're making it
a little bit sharper, but there we go.
We can see there, it was probably just the light
was making it a little bit harder to see.
So we'll leave that at a value of one.
The other thing that we're gonna do
is we are gonna adjust our dirt tile and our far tile.
So we're gonna set this dirt tile to 0.1.
So that's gonna give us
these kind of really nice looking edges there.
We are gonna set our far dirt tile to 0.01
and our far grass tile to 0.01.
I'm also gonna set our grass tile as well to 0.1
just to make things a little bit larger
because if we hit play here, whoops,
and definitely went in the wrong location there.
Let's find our player start here
and we're gonna just move this over
and move this up a little bit, there we go.
So let's hit play now.
So yeah, there we go, that's looking pretty good.
We've got a little stretching here,
but if we notice the displacement isn't working,
that's okay, we need to actually do something
to our landscape first to get our displacement.
So if we select our landscape here,
we're gonna come to enable Nanite
and then we'll just build this data.
And once we do that, we can get our displacement,
give us a chance to cook and look at that.
There is our landscape displacement looking all cool.
Little bit rocky up here,
or I should say a little bit too bumpy,
so we might wanna set this down to like 0.5.
And then smoothing this will make this
just work out a lot better.
Maybe we set this to 0.8, there we go,
that's looking a little bit better.
So really cool stuff right here
and then if I was to just right click and play,
the displacement will really help out,
just give this really great looking kind of like shadow
and in lighting and everything like that,
so it's working really well.
We can also see it there kind of off in the distance
as well working.
So this is good, this is what we want.
Now, if you have a problem with your material,
let's say that you have the exact opposite of this
where you have rock on the ground,
but grass kind of on the slopes.
One thing to check here inside of your material for this,
we're just gonna open up our landscape material again,
make sure that up here you have the dirt
and then the grass.
If you have the grass and then the dirt,
it will do the opposite effect of what you want.
So just make sure that you do have that enabled
and then we can adjust our settings and move on.